the City of London just announced a plan
to build bicycle roads connecting
underground stations subway stations so
it'll be overhead with walls on or
fences on two sides open on top and you
pay to get on them the same way that you
pay to get on the subway
it's a crazy town idea I've seen some
initial designs of them they were online
they're beautiful
funny looking and I mean this will
probably never get built right this is
one of those things that you think would
be a great idea but there's no money or
will for it but it's cool and the idea
would be that it would kind of sync up
or dovetail with the the existing bike
path network that they're building out
in London they've got these things
called bicycle super highways that are
on the ground and this is going on a lot
of big cities New York is doing
something similar right into where in
New York City there they've built out
kind of experimental bike paths that are
supposed to encourage bicycle transit
this got me thinking in cities we've
come to accept the idea that the car is
in charge and it doesn't have to be this
way my family goes for a long walk most
weekends and in the residential area
where I live my wife at the beginning of
these walks does this thing that makes
me crazy every time she she crosses the
streets diagonally cata Corner at
intersections and as a city kid that
makes me crazy because it sort of breaks
the rules she's usually looking for cars
we have two little kids and she's cook
with that stuff but it kind of rankles
right it rubs me the wrong way somehow
to be crossing in a way that doesn't
acknowledge that the car is supposed to
be in charge of course cars don't have
to be in charge right there are
developments going on around the world
where they're not the Bedford
zero-emission development in England for
example is at a train station and you
can drive to it but inside the
development you don't have a car it's
built so that people can get bicycles up
and down ramps and there are some other
places too they're built so that bikes
can go upstairs and can go around the
town township neighborhood whatever but
cars can't Masdar city in Abu Dhabi this
development they're doing that's
supposed to be zero emission there -
this is the same way you can drive to
the outskirts and park but it's built up
on a pedestal there's transit down below
kind of underground and all of the
streets are just pedestrian scale it's
been like this in cities before I mean
you know
cars have only been the dominant design
paradigm for about a century there are
parts of Philadelphia really popular
parts of Philadelphia where the streets
are so narrow you couldn't get a
mini-cooper through them because they
were built for you know people on
horseback and their residential people
liked them a lot
it makes me think that public
development or you know cities that the
governments of cities could find ways to
pick up on the lessons that commercial
developers have known for a long time
these urban entertainment destinations
like The Grove in Los Angeles for
example that are built to look sort of
City like they're really malls right but
the thing that most of them have in
common is that there's no cars allowed
in them it's like being on a city street
but it's only for pedestrians and bikes
I suppose a Main Street in Disneyland is
similar to this and Main Street I have
to admit is one of my guide stones when
it comes to urban design sorry I'm a
little bit you know when I was a kid
growing up in Los Angeles my friends I
used to do this thing late at night on
weekends we would drive downtown to the
financial district so it was totally
empty this was the eighties and we could
hear for miles you knew there were no
cars coming and we would park and we
would go to the middle of Grand Avenue
middle of downtown and lie down in the
middle of the street see who could do it
for the longest because even though we
knew that we were safe I mean you knew
there was a car coming for a long way
off even though we knew that
intellectually emotionally we were so
trained to think that the street
belonged to cars you couldn't stay there
for a long time we had to get up freaked
us out the same way that my wife
crossing that really freaks me out today
but I'm pitching there doesn't have to
be like this I'm saying we can start
designing parts of cities not entire
cities but parts of cities not for cars
but for people on foot and for bikes put
services in the alleys I don't care but
make them places where the cars aren't
in charge but where the people are